from the front page of YouTube to Ames
Iowa Hank green has been everywhere
worth being oh it's been great I've had
a great run it's been great but his fame
has come at some unexpected costs his
relationship with his Rocca fire
explosion hating brother John Green
already at a breaking point has been
pushed to its limits for chrissake John
have you even heard their Beatles medley
and who heard it it's beautiful and all
of this on the cusp of the release of
the internationally best-selling album
so jokes actually isn't out yet but it
will be internationally best-selling
depending on how you define that term
this is Hank green behind
kind of petrified move on to if Hermione
died or if Oldham are killed Hedwig just
three young
I ain't green was able to secure
internationally-recognized
blade all these are albums in created
music for that Saturday show SMED Mane's
who owns a music studio in Missoula
Montana daily sort of the music studio
in Missoula Montana
Schmidt is awesome Schmidt is like what
would happen if Weird Al Yankovic and
John Lennon had a baby and it was bald
most babies are bald together in the
studio Schmidt and Hank recorded many of
Hanks YouTube hits including Helen Hunt
I'm gonna kill you Edward spoon hands
Accio Deathly Hallows and book eggs
everyone the sleeves of JK Rowling I bet
have to do is give a big leave Alan to
protect up your blood pus face mouth boy
but Indiana I don't think it's gonna
matter its takes good early bad because
the weight of the rests on our boy it
was like a big awesome dream and every
time I went in there we need something
else it looks really awesome I'm gonna
kind of kick the vh1 thing in the button
now and tell you all that we are
officially releasing so jokes tomorrow
and we will have a big long blogtv party
tomorrow as well Allen who
coincidentally also made the intro for
this video thank you very much for doing
that in my dftba partner-in-crime
and he and a special guest are going to
be working all day long at the dftba
distribution center and the result of
their toiling labor is going to be that
all the people who pre-ordered their CDs
are going to get their CDs and the first
hundred are going to get signed CDs and
everyone starting tomorrow you can go to
dftba.com and order so jokes and it will
be sent immediately to your house and
I'm gonna be coming on in playing music
and talking about the album and talking
about music and talking about everything
and talking about song Wednesdays and
the future of brotherhood 2.0 in the
future 50ft VA records and my music in
general will be switching back and forth
and I think we're going to start about
five o'clock Eastern Time now let us
have more footage of excellent piano
playing and the end of us
like feigning tears
who wants you Debbie
deadly
daddy
I see
so if you are interested please please
go check out dftba.com and see if you
might want to purchase this thought I
worked hard on and I'm actually pretty
proud of so thank you all for supporting
my music and so jokes release party
beginning tomorrow we're probably going
to play I'm in like with you games and
then you're gonna hang out with Alan and
his special guest who is special you're
gonna hang out with me and then end me
in the hem it's gonna be that's fun I'm
so excited finally be getting to the
second of the world and John I will see
you Sunday if not before